I got this new necklace and I have not added a new necklace to like
my vibe in so long
and I just cleaned it
I am so obsessed with it
also if you've never gotten vintage sterling silver
I cannot tell you how satisfying it is
to clean the gunk off of vintage Sterling silver
in another life I think I definitely worked with Sterling silver
like either I was jeweler or as a cleaner or something
cause I do that a lot in my free time cause it's really fun
I love silver
this is what it looked like when I bought it
do you see how like black and like dirty this necklace is
like I love it but it's like black and dirty and like oxidite
also I spent $63 on it which is like a little bit much
but it is 53 ounces of silver
a heavy necklace
in the way that I gauge whether or not I should buy Sterling silver
also I don't know if this is right
but this is my like biggest silver purchase
it's $200 it was 400 leva (for my 22nd birthday) I got in Bulgaria translates $200
and this is 64 ounces of Sterling silver
to be fair it is I think like hand
apparently it's like hands made so that also makes it more expensive
but since this was 64 ounces for $200
this being 53 ounces for $63 feel like was a good deal
also now that it's clean
look how good it looks anyways
also I realized on the days that I wanna show more cleve
I have to wear less necklaces cause they kind of like
they all just sit
sit here and interrupt on vibe
you know them tryna
I also got these from Arizona
that's my new jewelry